one Chicago MBC's sprawling shared
universe of procedural drama set in the
Windy City has naturally experienced
quite a bit of turnover here are the
actors who left the one Chicago
franchise and the reasons for doing so
Gabriela Dawson could do everything on
Chicago Fire the sister of Chicago PD's
Antonio Dawson Gaby started her career
arc as the paramedic in charge for
ambulance 61
then after briefly becoming a
firefighter she returned to her first
love as a paramedic
Gaby finally decided that Chicago wasn't
for her and moved to Puerto Rico to run
a rescue operation
actor Monica Raymond's exit was
surprising because she'd been with
Chicago Fire throughout its first six
seasons as Raymond told the Chicago
Tribune
I knew that my six-year contract was
coming to an end and I felt like I was
hungry to explore a different role a
different story Leslie Shay portrayed by
Lauren German in the first two seasons
of Chicago Fire was a capable paramedic
who held her own in the tough world of
firehouse 51 a well-liked character who
was a fan favorite too many it was
shocking when Shay was killed off in
Chicago fires third season premiere her
death concluded a cliffhanger from the
previous season in which first
responders fell for a fire trap set by a
serial arsonist from a creative
standpoint Shay died because the death
of a central figure would provide an
emotional wallop to the audience as
executive producer Matt Olmstead told TV
Line going into it we knew it had to be
someone who was going to give us a big
impact as opposed to going for a
lesser-known character which would
equate to a pulled punch the producer
revealed that he and the show's writers
considered each and every major
character ultimately going with Shay
because quote it affected the most
people Peter mills was something of an
audience surrogate on Chicago Fire with
fans seeing the exciting and often
frightening world of big-city
firefighting through his eyes taking on
the same job as his late father Mills
was a rookie firefighter when the show
began in 2012 in the third season he
saved the life in his first call out
only decide that what he really wanted
to do was work in his family's
restaurant in North Carolina don't think
for one second I don't know
lucky event I will never forget that
actor Charlie Barnet found out he was
about to lose his job from producers
just before the exit episode taped
Barnett told the Sarasota Herald Tribune
I hadn't heard anything about it and
then they pulled me into a room set me
down and apologized Barnett went on to
say that the writer on the show felt
that his character had quote reached a
plateau Steven R McQueen joined Chicago
Fire in its fourth season as truck 81
firefighter and paramedic Jimmy Borrelli
the character receives a big emotional
arc when his brother perishes in a fire
which causes Borelli to blame chief
Boden the personal and workplace tension
subsides when Morelli is severely
injured in an explosion which robbed him
of an eye the incident ended the career
of fir alley as well as McQueen's time
on Chicago fire after just 24 episodes
as executive producer Michael Brandt
later explained it wasn't an option to
get rid of Eamonn Walker who has
portrayed chief Boden since the series
started grant told TV Line Eamon has
been with us since day one he was the
first character we cast Jon seda joined
NBC's 1 Chicago franchise as chief
investigator Antonio Dawson a recurring
character on Chicago Fire before the
debut of Chicago PD where he was a main
character seda continued to be the link
throughout dick Wolf's universe of Windy
City public servants leaving PD for the
short-lived Chicago Justice in 2017
after that shows swift cancellation SATA
and Dawson headed back to Chicago PD for
another two years early in the seventh
season Dawson suffering from a relapse
to pill addiction resigns from the force
and moves to Puerto Rico according to a
source close to the show who spoke to
Deadline writers had done all they could
do with the character creatively and
opted to get rid of him the star of the
ensemble drama Chicago PD Sophia Bush's
image featured prominently in
promotional materials for the series
seeing as she was already famous from
her time on One Tree Hill
and yet Bush had no choice but to leave
the popular series where she'd spent
four years playing the complex Erin
Lindsay a teen criminal turned
intelligence unit detective Chicago PD
writers sent her off by having Lindsay
accept an offer to work with the
be I in New York I need an address
Bush had a hard time working through the
harsh Chicago winters and said her body
was quote falling apart because she was
so unhappy producers refused to let her
out of her seven-year contract leaving
Bush to issue an ultimatum as Bush
explained on Dax Shepherds armchair
expert podcast I said okay you can put
me in the position of going quietly of
my own accord or you can put me in the
position of suing the network to get out
of my deal and I'll write an op-ed for
the New York Times and tell them why the
producers eventually let Bush out of her
deal officer Sean Roman a--sometimes a
hot-headed patrol cop who runs a
security company when he's off duty was
transferred to Chicago PD's to one
because he'd become romantically
involved with another officer toward the
end of Chicago PD's third season Roman
is shot in the line of duty and
seriously wounded hinting at a tragic
end for his character he ultimately
pulls through and given the choice of
transferring to semi active duty or
quitting the force he chooses the latter
and moves to San Diego while the exit of
his character and the means by which he
did it were a surprise it's apparently
what Chicago PD producers and actor
Brian Geraghty had in mind all along Mac
when they were trying to cast Roman the
producers wanted Garrity in the role
Garrity was interested but one of the
year two year contract so he could leave
the show when he felt like it was time
to move on and with enough advance
warning to give Roman a proper send-off
most of the action in Chicago med the
hospital component of the one Chicago
franchise takes place in the emergency
room at Gaffney Chicago Medical Center
every day it's doctors and nurses work
to save lives with medical students
Sarah Reese in the fray along with them
what ultimately sends dr. Reese away
from Chicago med and off to Texas is a
personal tiff with dr. Charles played by
Oliver Platt when he learns that Reese's
father might be a murderer
by the time actress Rachel de pillow
started playing doctor Reese on Chicago
med she had amassed plenty of TV credits
however since leaving the Chicago shows
in 2018 des pillow hasn't appeared in
any movies or TV shows and has mostly
been a ghost on social media except for
a few tweets in 2020 so while we may not
know exactly why she left it's
seems like she left acting behind
completely check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]